vamos a pensar un poco en que eso que
representa tomarme dos tercios dos
tercios y multiplicar a esto multiplicar
esto por 6 por 6 y bueno es que hay dos
formas de ver esta multiplicación la
podemos ver de una primera manera
diciendo que tenemos que tomarnos dos
tercios seis veces es decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que dos tercios dos
tercios y más dos tercios más dos
tercios más dos tercios más dos tercios
más
y dos tercios
dos tercios es decir me estoy tomando
dos tercios y lo estoy sumando consigo
mismo seis veces dicho de otra manera
esto es lo mismo que dos tercios por
seis y bueno esto de aquí esto de aquí
sabemos cuánto es porque tenemos el
mismo denominador y cuando tenemos el
mismo denominador lo podemos sacar como
denominador común y esto es lo mismo que
3 el 3 queda abajo y arriba podemos
tener a 2 más 2 más 2 más 2 más 2 más 2
lo cual es lo mismo que 2 por 6 2 por 6
ok
antes de ponerlo con este color o
también lo podemos ver si ya realizamos
la suma común a 2 por 6 es 12 12 /
dividido entre 3 ok es decir que dos
tercios por 6 es 12 tercios ahora lo
padre de este asunto es que 12 tercios
también lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera déjame ponerlo aquí 12 sobre
sobre
12 sobre 3 lo puedo ver a como 3
déjame poner una línea grande déjame
poner aquí a este de aquí voy a
conservar el mismo denominador y arriba
voy a poner al 12 pero escrito de la
siguiente manera como 3 + 3 ok más tres
más tres y estoy haciendo esto porque
entonces voy a poder obtener lo
siguiente esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tomarme 3 3 entre 3 3 entre 3 ya
esto sumarle 3 antes gm también de color
3 entre 3 entre 3 ok ya esto es más de
otra vez 3 entre 3 3 entre entre déjame
cambiar de color 3 ya esto sumarle para
finalizar otra vez 3 3 entre 3 entre 3 y
lo estoy poniendo de esta manera porque
quiero que te des cuenta que nosotros
sabemos de una manera muy fácil cuántos
3 entre 3 tres tercios es lo mismo que
uno y lo hemos visto en varios vídeos
cuando tenemos que el numerador y el
denominador es el mismo eso es lo mismo
que 1
esto también es 1 ok esto también es 1
ok
esto también es 1 ok y entonces podemos
decir que 12 tercios es exactamente lo
mismo que uno más uno más uno más uno lo
cual es cuatro aunque doce tercios
podemos concluir que es cuatro y esta es
una manera de verlo dos tercios por seis
es lo mismo que tomarme la suma de dos
tercios consigo mismo seis veces y
obtenemos que eso es lo mismo que cuatro
esa es una manera de ver esta
multiplicación pero también lo podemos
ver en sentido contrario podemos
tomarnos seis y para esto qué te parece
si hago una recta numérica déjame hacer
una recta en américa supongamos que
exista el cero
y entonces voy a hacerme directo
numérica que llegue hasta el 6
supongamos que por acá hasta el 6 ok
entonces tengo 1
por acá hasta el 2 por acá está el 3 por
acá hasta el 4 por acá está el 5 ok por
acá hasta el 6 ya tengo 6 enteros y si
yo me iba a tomar dos terceras partes de
sus seis enteros bueno puedo pensar que
esto estoy déjenme cambiar de color para
que lo veas mucho más claro voy a
cambiarlo con este color no voy a tomar
a dos espera creo que es el mismo color
o un color muy parecido no mejor este
color ahora voy a tomarme de aquí hasta
acá de aquí hasta acá como un entero
completo ahora voy a suponer que este de
aquí es un entero completo y me quiero
tomar dos terceras partes de ese entero
completo así que vamos a dividir lo
primero en tres partes iguales y si te
das cuenta aquí tendría una de estas
tres partes iguales y aquí tendría otra
de estas tres partes iguales aquí una y
aquí otro y cuando yo me quiera tomar
dos tercios dos tercios de estos seis
enteros realmente lo que estoy haciendo
es dando un primer salto hasta acá y
después un segundo salto hasta acá
y ya te diste cuenta que el número
llegamos llegamos al 4 otra vez y bueno
tiene mucho sentido es lógico que
hayamos llegado al 4 porque dos tercios
por seis pues es lo mismo que seis por
dos tercios si llegáramos a un resultado
distinto realmente nos tendríamos que
preocupar pero bueno como llegamos al
mismo resultado lo que quiero que veas
en este vídeo es que hay dos formas de
comprender esta multiplicación que tengo
aquí dos tercios por 6
es lo mismo que tomarme la suma de dos
tercios consigo mismo seis veces ok
como esta de aquí o en su dado caso
tomarme dos terceras partes de estas
seis unidades divide al seis entre tres
y tomarme dos terceras partes y llego al
mismo resultado que es cuatro de lujo